hi my name is Olivia lanes and welcome back to Quantum Computing in practice this is episode two Quantum
circuits we're going to be covering several topics in today's lecture but what I want you to walk away knowing are the following three things one what IBM
quantum computers actually are so that you at least have a rough picture in your mind of what you're doing when you send a job to one of those over the
cloud two what kuit is what Primitives are and how we can use them to create create and execute Quantum circuits
we'll also discuss at a high level the different types of IBM Quantum processors available and what distinguishes one from another and three
lastly the typical workflow that we follow to run experiments at scale this includes selecting the best Primitives
for your use case mapping a problem to a Quantum circuit and applying error suppression and mitigation which enable
us to squeeze as much power out of these machines as possible now there's a lot of information here but stick with me
because soon enough we're going to put it all together in the context of some real examples first let's briefly discuss cubits and the actual Quantum
Hardware as an experimentalist I can promise you that it is fascinating and it really helps connect the dots to
visualize what's actually happening when jobs are sent to a quantum computer through the cloud the processors that
we're going to be using are built with superconducting transmon cubits here's what a small IBM quantum processor looks
like now these small squares here are the cubits themselves so there are a total of five on this chip the transmon
itself is a capacitor and it consists of two plates of metal hooked up in paril with a nonlinear inductor called the
Jose injunction but to see the Joseph injunction you actually have to zoom in even more it's created from two
overlapping layers of superconducting metal and where the two pieces overlap and touch is the junction a Jose
Junction is an element that can be used to create an artificial atom with multiple energy levels and we isolate
the bottom two energy levels as our Cubit State the squiggly lines here represent the microwave resonators
basically 2D transmission lines coupled to the Cubit now when we program a gate that essentially equates to choosing a
highly calibrated microwave pulse and the specific frequency amplitude shape and duration of those pulses make the
Cubit do specific things the instructions for the microwave pulse go from your computer to the cloud and
then are read and interpreted by room temperature control Electronics which take those instructions and physically
generate the pulses we call them microwave pulses because they all fit within the microwave frequency bandwidth
which is around 1 GHz after the room temperature control boxes create the pulses they travel through the cables
into the dilution refrigerator and eventually to our Quantum chip the signal goes into the resonators through
a wire Bond on these pads and then it flows down the transmission line into our cubits now I know this all might
have been a little Technical and these details aren't crucial to understand for us going forward but I hope now that you
can all at least picture the physical system that you're all about to interact with so where do these quantum computers
actually exist well IBM has dozens of quantum computers all around the world and we've recently upgraded our Fleet to
contain only 100 plus Cubit processors as I mentioned in the previous lesson some of them are located in an IBM
Quantum data center in Upstate New York those systems are deployed all over the cloud for everyone's use and some of
them are dedicated on premise systems complete with all of the electronics to make them work that support our partners
in the IBM quantum network now let's talk about kcit which is IBM's open-source software development kit
designed to work on quantum computers from now on I'll be referring to this as the kkit SDK there's also the kkit
ecosystem which is a collection of software tutorials and functions that build on or extend the core functionalities of kkit as well as kkit
runtime which is a Quantum Computing service and programming model that allows users to design and efficiently
execute their Quantum workloads by using kcit Primitives and A Primitive is basically a small building block that
you can use to design larger circuits or a job the two Primitives that are most important to us are going to be the
sampler and the estimator which we'll discuss in more depth shortly if you haven't downloaded and installed the
kiss kit SDK yet there is no time like the present kiss kit 1.0 was recently released and it's more performative and
stable than ever before so for those of you that are just getting started you came in at the perfect time for those of
you that are already familiar with kcit you'll need to download and reinstall the newest version we recommend using
pip to install kiss kit and kiss kit runtime and running them through a Jupiter notebook in a web browser of your choice so you're also going to need
to install jupyter notebook or Jupiter lab in case you haven't done that already these tools are all free and you
can get them up and running on your own local machine without any cost make sure to add kiss kit with the visualization
option dependencies so it works with Jupiter and lets you plot things you will also need to set up a virtual python environment and there are
instructions on how to do this on the kit install page linked here once you've become familiar with kkit and you're
ready to run jobs on real quantum computers you'll need to register at quantum.com and create an IBM Quantum
API token and there is also a link for here for that a detailed walkthrough of how to do this follow all the
instructions in our documentation page like I mentioned or you can watch the coding with kkit installation video here
both of which are linked and in the description now we're just about ready to start talking about Quantum
circuits since the point of this course is to teach you the audience how to scale up your jobs to be run at 100 plus
Cubit scale I believe the most constructive way forward is to First consider the overall workflow that we're going to follow and the easiest way to
understand a typical Quantum Computing workflow is through kiss kit patterns kiss kit patterns are a conceptual framework allowing users to run Quantum
workloads by implementing certain steps with modular tooling this allows Quantum Computing task to be performed by
powerful heterogeneous Computing infrastructure these steps can be performed as a service and can
incorporate Resource Management which allows for seamless composability of new capabilities as they are developed here
are the main steps which experienced kcit users will likely already recognize the first step is mapping this step
formalizes how we take a general problem that we're interested in and figure out how to map it in into a quantum computer
in the form of a circuit next we optimize in this step we use the kkit transpiler to route and lay out the
circuit onto an actual physical Quantum Hardware this includes translating the individual Quantum Gates into sequences